one thing I've noticed about this code
is it's a bit spaghettified what you
mean like it's falling into a black hole
white memory it's an astronomy thing
it's spaghettified as in it's a mess of
if statements and loops let's break this
down into some more manageable chunks by
using some functions functions are
awesome hey have you read the book East
of Eden by John Steinbeck this isn't a
literature class
I know but stick with me this is
relevant I was reading it the other day
and there was a passage that struck me
the story takes place around the turn of
the century and one of the characters
named Adam gets a car this is a big deal
because cars were really new back then
you couldn't just stick a key in the
ignition and get rolling
there was a long intricate process of
priming the ignition getting oxygen into
the engine etc the boys in the story had
a mantra that they kept repeating to
help themselves remember the process but
all of this is automated now right turn
the key start the car right you know in
the book the characters had to pass
instructions about the way engines work
in order to start the car today all of
those instructions are bundled in the
act of turning the key functions do
basically the same thing they bundle
instructions together so if I had a
start car function it would abstract
away all the intricacies of starting a
car yeah exactly okay that was a decent
example functions in JavaScript can be
defined with two different syntaxes the
first should look pretty familiar if
you've been paying attention
we start with far followed by the
function name in this case my func
equals and then the work keyword
function an optional parameter list and
then the body of the function this
keyword function tells the JavaScript
engine that we're making a function and
this is the second syntax in this case
we actually don't have to start with var
we just start with this keyword function
and then we give our function a name
which in this case is still my funk then
after my funk
we have optional parameters inside
parentheses and then the body of the
code goes between the two curly braces
just the same way we do with if
statements and loops these two syntaxes
are pretty much equivalent there are
subtle differences in the way that
javascript engine interprets these two
different functions however they go
beyond the scope of this course so check
the instructors notes if you're
interested in learning more seems to me
we should bundle the code we just used
to populate the work experience inside
the display work function yeah let's do
that and see what happens
here's a quiz for you we want you to
move all the code you just wrote to
display the work into a function called
display work make sure you put all of
your code between the curly braces but
don't do anything else after you move
your code in to display work what
happens when you refresh the page pick
one of these two answers do you see the
same thing or does nothing appear at all
in the work section